hey how you doing guys you and your
partners part a substantial amount of
money from my benefactor and in light of
recent events he's concerned about
getting paid back he wants to sit down
tomorrow don't forget to bring your
buddies
Jerry said he wanted to talk to all
those actually he said he won't talk to
everyone but the black yes oh gosh I am
so sorry I'm late traffic you owe me 400
grand I'm offering you gentlemen a way
out
oh all you have to do is collect the
stealer hold him for 24 hours we're not
criminals
if you do this for me I will consider
the slate clean don't check out monkey
you go okay the head of the black crime
syndicates nephew was kidnapped are you
kidding me
it doesn't lesson to be learned here
today
somebody's big in voice finish having a
good day
what are you doing okay oh great he's I
you screwed us occupational hazard
you know who this guy was that means
y'all are pretty much
where's Marcus Flemming oh you know
something
oh man I'm sorry my bad I don't feel
well there's been a change of plan Eddie
you're gonna do exactly what I want you
to do okay this ends right now
is that my gun oh no - its icing on the
cake
bori vice do we feel I mentioned to get
to a cathouse if you like exactly look
upon us
that's finds his father guess that's
just a Fiat